a trailblazer
every single person in this room is
trailblazing whether it's within or
without for years they've been looking
for like who is the next person the next
evolution of what Oprah Winfrey started
and I think that now they have found her
and what does that feel like to be in
that position now you know there's only
one Oprah I don't even like it's not
even it's like an evolution it's like
Oprah's her own her own things so I
think it's in a whole nother category
you know I think I think it's just I
feel good to be able to create a
platform that
we can have these kind of conversations
that we're having I feel really really
honored and I feel like something I'm
meant to do you know what I mean and so
it's a good how does it feel to have
this award and be honored tonight and
the love is you're giving your family
and they're giving back to you yeah it
was really nice it was nice to see
Alicia and Latifah Tiffany I mean these
are my girls and so for them to show me
that kind of love is really awesome and
it's just so wonderful to be here you
know with the with the audience here to
be able to be able to share love with
them as well so good
[Music]